hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation crispr-powered
biosensors this webinar is part of the
fourth annual crispr virtual event i am
antonina salcido of labrutz and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
now let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to first participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation you can find the live chat
located at the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker dr can
denture junior research group leader at
fit and mtech at the university of
freiburg germany
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
and you may now begin your presentation
thanks for this kind introduction
welcome everybody from uh germany
freiburg i hope where you are you are
all good and today we're gonna speak
about crispr-powered biosensors so i
have an
um a little bit whole program starting
with the biosensors what are the
challenges right now with the biosensors
coming up with um
how to combine these with a crisper
crisper cut system so
let's start
so
first of all i would like to
say that
sensors actually are going to change to
disposable sensors and what does it mean
so
here we need low cost single use and
easy to handle sensing devices for short
term or single shot measurements so such
a devices are required since they could
transduce physical chemical or
biological changes in their environment
to analytical signal
um and these devices are already
actually in our life
um like for example the pregnancy test
where we have a single use only and then
we throw the device away and what why
they are so powerful and also due to the
pandemic of course getting so important
because these class of sensors enable us
to get the physiological information by
anyone anywhere and at any time without
worrying about the contamination as well
as
needing a recalibration so therefore
disposable
so but of course disposable devices
could be also not only a whole device
for single use they could be also
combined with for example uh like the
evaluation test
um so this could be combine a digital
regular together with a disposable part
and here the examples which i showed
were some obstacles are basing on the
optical detection based on the optical
detection and there are of course also
others and other prominent uh detection
type is the electrochemical system and
here we have mainly the glucose
monitoring systems which are made to
break through and come to in our daily
life
and i choose here of course a little bit
more um
not that usual example with a with a
glucose strip and then reader so you can
combine these meanwhile also
as a sugar watch into your
into your watches
but also
electrochemical glucose monitoring has
also go another step forward and also
has now a variable system which allows
us for example here the free style
library from abbott which allows a
variable deduction of glucose
concentration continuously for 14 days
and
um
and here you see also the the
differences of the devices as well as
how they are used in our daily life
but again the question why this
disposability is so important what is
the drive behind so of course the most
important factor
is the economic efficiency it's wild and
it will be most probably also staying
um so here we need in high production
at an extremely low cost at minimum
quantities of materials
not only the substrate materials but
also the biological materials for a
single sensor unit
but there are
also other factors like
now the the the like fridays for future
and getting these
uh
um
this is actions so it forces us to make
environmental sustainability available
so we are thinking now not only
producing the material and also use it
but also what happens after that and
here of course it's some some future
trends is definitely recyclables are
there but we are now moving on to the
biodegradable systems
as i already mentioned the main
factor one of the other main factor in
the diagnostics is the contamination of
samples so reusability is
something which maybe adds something to
your sensing system as a value but
um in the general way you don't want to
measure different samples of different
patients with the same sensor um since
you are deciding um the the life or
death situation
and if any contamination could lead
fossil uh
um
problems and of course
the importance of the recalibration so
we would like to have easy system
everyone at home could be able to use it
without any uh difficulty so
and the independent of what they study
what they learned and how much they know
that it should be really simple to
understand and also
um done at
home or at any facility that we
could think about it
um regarding the disposable sensors i
think something which is nice for such
an educational tool is how they build
and here we have a business model behind
so um which is called razor razor blade
business model and this is actually
credited to king complete who who found
the company gillette
um
and actually it is as i said credited
because actually he did not invented
this
but he was the most successful person
who is using this razor razor blade
business model and actually and it is
credited to him what he invented was
actually double h saved eraser but
anyway um so the thing was actually the
company has has got an offer in the
first world war uh from the u.s army
where he made and he gets his contract
and made these razor razor blades sell
to the soldier or give to the soldiers
and of course over the war time they get
used to it and this habit they brought
home if they came there they continued
to use uh these razor razor blade from
king kong tillet which helps the
gillette company to be to get bigger so
um
i think this song may be a little bit
off topic but i think this is still
important to understand how you if you
are dealing with sensors how are you
going to promote them what should be the
strategy behind to sell or to
to produce them and here of course the
main idea is marketing single-use
consumables
along with a non-disposable
low cost or even free devices to
increase the recur the recurring revenue
and this is of course not only for the
for the for the razor razor blades you
can find it also with the ink for the
inkjet printers
um
and of course we have this also as i
show you on the glucose test strip for
example as a razor blade
or
the glucometer as a razor which is
reusable and inexpensive reader so i
think this is also important to
understand the basics behind um the
sensor and sensing devices on in overall
since it is important
later on to to adapt these systems
together with the crispr
i will finish this part with the
requirements of current disposable
centers as i said we are going to the
inexpensive sustainable and even
biodegradable materials
overall we need high modular devices
which have fever components so it's it's
important so that you have a really
compact device at the end and
and of course again it should be
reliable and low cost offering and mass
production
um you need shorter sample result time
so for a point of care testing
application for on-site measurements you
need be sure less than two hours but of
course if you
if it's faster than it's better um if
you have an enzymatic sensor then it's
important so you have the thought
response times so that any change which
happens in the in the in the in the body
you can detect
now and not one hour later so the the
response times are important otherwise
you can miss some events
um overall it should be easy to use or
offer an automatic handling of the
sample samples with minimum user
intervention and at the end of course it
could be operated with an instrument
with a low cost or portable or without
this depends on the application in the
final
and of course an important point you are
moving from the clinical laboratory to
one side but what you of course take
with you is the precise results with the
international standard so you cannot be
birther while you are just can do it on
site so you should be at least
comparable with the um
with the current standards used at the
laboratory with your system
and of course this is maybe something
which is i think also an important point
anyway what kind of sensor you are
developing
um it's important to think about it
like non-technological challenges for
example if people will accept this in
their daily life so if you are designing
a variable device would people like to
carry these or you can make it for
example a very good device which can
measure very powerful measurements but
the problem at the end will be no one
will pay the money that you are offering
it although maybe your device is too
powerful for this application so i think
these all um aspects we need to be
considered before we start building
sensors
so
um
what what my group in freiburg are
actually working on is we have four four
different current uh research areas uh
which i would like to really shortly go
on and then start with the with our
crisper work so um
first of all we are working with
multiplexing which means nowadays we do
not want to measure a single analyte we
would like to measure different analytes
to have a more accurate picture of a
disease or to um to detect different
diseases or different
physiological conditions at the same
time and here
we are working with antibiotics
inflammation markers and of course
nutrient acids
a little bit side applications of what
we are working on on also bringing these
on-site devices a little bit more
uh near to us so coming to the variables
we are
developing and love on a bird system
where we would like to implement an
immunoassay based hormone detection on
3d moving birds here of course our first
model are chicken and we we would like
to
establish a device which is capable to
draw blood continuously every two hours
and bring it to the sensor do a
classical eliza on the chip and and the
result will be taken
with via via wireless
to you to our smart devices so this is
the one of the projects that we are
working on
another one um
a little bit away from these is is using
opto genetic switches to create dynamic
assay so we would like to use their
light regulated and in reversible
interaction
by
binding them these protein of interest
and use the light to bind and release
them to create and wash free eliza for
example using a smartphone
um
which i think is also essay we will
hopefully publish soon so that you can
get more information
and the last part is the paper-based
bread analysis which is which also in my
group also done so
this is typical paper-based sensors
which you all might know but our idea
was to use it for a variable device for
non-continuous and
continuous and non-invasive monitoring
and our idea was to use the humidity
that we are exhaling
to make this paper wet in a for example
in a face mask and do continuous
electrochemical measurements and here we
are working on hydrogen peroxide and
glucose um due to limited time today i
won't speak about it um
but
if you have there are also publications
in my group so which you can find today
i'm gonna talk about what is highlighted
um i think the last area highlights
highlighted in nature biotechnology last
year in the covet 19th super wave of
innovative diagnostic about our
multiplex crispr biosensor
and what we are doing with this
um
actually i was thinking about skipping
this slide but i thought it's an
educational
meeting today so i decided to keep it
and
let's start why we need nuclear acid
testing so of course we would like to
prevent diagnose and treatment of
diseases so treatment monitoring of
diseases
and why this is important of course in
case of emergence or re-emergent
outbreak of infectious diseases
like the coronavirus that we are the
kovis 19 pandemic that we are living on
i know here of course as you can see
it's a huge global problem and we need
uh fast and reliable diagnostics on site
so that the infected person can be can
we go into into the quarantine and the
spreading of the disease could be slowed
or even even um completely disappear
um until the vaccines or whatever the
the medicine is help us to to fight with
this pandemic
um
this is of course the one case but what
why my group is started is actually was
the
normal nipple acid-base biomarkers like
the micrornas and micrornas are kind of
told about as a garbage of cells
and and currently
there there is their font there is found
some correlation of
and not only one microrna but different
micron a levels
to indicating specific diseases and so
this is also why why we are interested
in the
at the first side with the nuclear acid
testing and here again maybe in the
micrornas they are really short rna so
um
[Music]
and maybe speaking to that here we have
a gold standard of course the
quantitative polymerase chain reaction
you all might know so this is the qpcr
and here if you are working with rna
rnase or rna-based viruses um you need
to first reverse transcript rna into the
complementary dna in order to make the
later the isothermal amplification
um but here um it is not easy if you are
dealing with micro rnas because as i
said they are really short uh sequences
so this this is the first problem that
you are will most probably um face
and of course uh with the goal goals
with the cooper cr you have a time
intensive and expensive method in
comparison
to the biosensor based approach
and here another important thing limited
multiplexing and on-site capability of
the ku pcr system
is also a problem
and here um
of course we need
diagnostic devices for simultaneous
easily scalable which means you can
adapt for new targets easily your system
without changing that much parameters
and i think amplification free target
amplification free on-site detection of
multiple nuclear assets in human body
fluids and that was actually our
starting point and this is also
something which we are still of course
working
and here
we started with the crispr in i think it
was end of 2017 18 we started with with
working crispr power diagnostics and
here in the crispr power diagnostics you
can find currently two different modes
the first mode of course after the
isolation and the purification of the
sample the the first mode that you could
use and this is also used by tiana
around and colleagues at cake institute
um
to create the first um crisper chip the
electrical
crisper chip which is based on the
binding detection so they used and
deactivated uh cas9
which can bind to its target and in that
case they look in the genome some
specific mutations and if it binds to
the chip
due to the
charges of the um
the sequence you can see an electrical
change which you can detect
um
amplification free in that case so um
and this is the first case so here the
cleavage part of the crisper enzymes are
actually deactivated
um
the next type that you could use is the
cleavage base and in the cleavage base
actually the cost is working completely
uh in in completely functional so here
um if you
maybe if you start with the target
sequence below
um so you would see if there is a target
sequence this car cost enzyme get
activated and cleave all surrounding
rnas except the target rna so in that
case um
the the defensang and colleagues use
and brought and reported molecule
like the reporter rna which can be
cleaved and resulting in a signal and
use this violation visualization
technique to to see the the the
concentration of the target and
um
these two techniques can be used for the
crispr power diagnostic like cleavage or
binding and
since cleavage base is a time depending
of course and it's a time depending uh
process so you can achieve higher uh
sensitivities using the the only the
enzymatic activity so therefore uh we
decided to go with the cleavage-based
systems
um maybe before starting with our work
why maybe crispr is getting so prominent
or it's already in the bio-fencing world
is also very prominent so the thing is
we have some different cost effectors
that we are currently using like top 13
cos cos
cast 12 or cup c even we have a cuff
from a doctor of age
um found i think last year by the by the
dartmouth group and so there are lots of
different uh
cut enzymes and there are lots of out
there so um and the toolbox of crispr is
really huge and um so it offers many
possibilities
and we use this cleavage-based
uh system
to create the first electrochemical
crispr powered
vital sensor
and how our system is working so we have
on one side the cost 13a as an enzyme
which you could
program by using a crispr rna and here
in the in the crispr rna you see the
blue part which is complementary to your
targets here
so if you are targeting another
microrna in our case for example or
other irony the only thing that you need
to change is these blue parts of the
crispr rna and we use also similar to
the sherlock the um similar or the same
reporter rna with the biotin and
anti-fluorescein tag
which we later
combined with an electrochemical with an
enzyme to create electrochemical signals
so it's very easy the only thing that
you need to do is mix these three
components together with a sample in an
epi and waste according to your uh
protocol it could be five minutes to 21
a day at the given temperature it could
be also a deferred used by the by the
enzyme that we are using for cast 13a it
was the
um 37 degrees and if you have
in our case for example no target
microrna
um the crystal cost does not get
activated and the reporter is not
cleaved so that if you are putting in
our electrochemical sensors with a
typical for example using streptavidin
biotin binding which is blocked with a
bsa and then bind it with an enzyme
with glucose oxidase and an
anti-fluorescent antibody so we can
convert glucose to hydrogen peroxide
which we can electrochemically sense
later
what happens if we have a target in the
sample so the crispr cut gets activated
and the reporter is cleaved so i'm
imagining always i gave always the same
example so it's like a pac-man going
through the epi and
clipping all the reports or rnas
um depending on the time you gave it
um
and here
um
what and of course the biotinylated part
still can't bind to the surface but the
signal generating part is just washed
away and so your signal is decreasing if
you there's a target so from the sa
behavior you can compare it with a
competitive effect so you get a
competitive essay behavior
so this is the whole system what you
need
and as i said why crispr is
attracting so many people right now in
the biosensing field is exactly the the
thing that i said at the beginning of
this slide so if you want to target
another
rna for example the only thing in your
whole system is
to change the crisper rna and you can
program your device so your biosensing
part completely stays as it is so you
don't need to change anything so you
have a very high scalable system another
thing which is important
and we also use it is
due to this timely time dependent
cleavage you can skip
for of course
losing some sensitivity the the target
amplification which we also done
um
just talking a little bit about the
biosensor itself we have a polymer-based
biosensor um containing three electrodes
for the electrochemical sensing and
these electrochemical sensing part and
the immobilization area are separated so
we are not
doing the complete assay onto our
electrodes but separating it within with
this
um which is called here sp stopping
barrier um so that
here our fa is done by giving a droplet
to the inlet which is fields until to
the sd part stopping barrier which is
teflon coated
channel
so uh and then we suck it from the
insane inlet the solution back so which
allows us to work with different kinds
of essay type and also even whole blood
or saliva or any any sample type that
you can use
you can use this using our system
um
about the essay i won't talk so it's the
same which i already mentioned in the
previous slide
um but the electrochemical cell later on
of course uh what we introduce is
glucose and then give
glucose oxidase time to convert glucose
to hydrogen peroxide which we push to
the electrochemical cell to the electro
working electrodes and and get a signal
peak which we then later on use for the
for the measurement
okay this is the system behind so what
are the results
um
okay okay sorry um what can
electrochemical crispr diagnosis deliver
so we show that it's highly sensitive so
our target was micro na19b which is um
belongs to the micro nh 17 to 92 family
cluster family so this is a different
micrornas showing and very highly
aggressive prey tomorrow on on children
um
middle of blastoma is also called so and
micro n90b is a member of this group and
it's uh highly expressed if you have
this tomorrow
and here we show that our system is
calibrated our system
gives a statistical um this is it really
important so um we are using statistical
with any cool aid
delivered 10 pico mole by three hours
cleavage so what we can achieve
picomolar range without target
amplification and if you compare these
with with optical devices using cop13a
we are five times better than these
devices in the same
cleavage time
so as i talk about it um
so of course not only important is the
sensitivity but also specificity because
um it's important to differentiate
between these different micrornas so
that they not trigger any any cleavage
and here
um we tested our system
um with micro n19b was our target we
tested with micron in 19a which differs
only a single base and and micro na 197
which is almost a complement to
completely different uh micro rna and
what we see in the north target we have
as i said competitive behavior so we
have a very high signals and if we have
um these micro na
197 we have also very high signals which
which means there is no cleavage in 19b
we see a cleavage as expected and if you
mix these 19b and 197 together
we see again if the system works as it's
expected
um
we also see two micron in 19a which
differs as i said only one single base
we see it cleavage but still we can
differentiate these and
actually if you know
the problem
microrna or rna that you are competing
with so you can also build some
mismatches in your crispr rna to get
increase your specificity in our case
that was not a big problem because micro
name 19a belongs also the same
microarray cluster for metalloblastoma
which means actually
this is also highly expressed in our
sample so
um
as i said one of the main advantages is
we have a easily reprogrammable system
so and to show that we use micrornas 20a
which we only change if you can remember
the blue part of the crispr rna and and
we directly achieve a calibration curve
where we get a limit of detection around
50 pico mole for this micro rna and so
you can change all of
changing this blue part a lot of you be
scalable and
um
yeah
next thing which we would like to check
was actually the cleavage time effect to
the limits to the sensitivity as well as
the dynamic range that we can measure so
this is the range um here between the
max maximum and minimum where we can see
something differentiate
a signal and here we check one one hour
to 24 hours what we see as expected the
limits of deduction uh gets better so we
get for one hour two pickup alerts uh to
one day two picomolar but the dynamic
gains range get also narrow and in the
one one uh one hour we get 18 pico moles
but the dynamic range is much more wider
so depending on the on your application
you need to check the cleavage time and
adapt it either you want to have a very
highly
sensitive system or or you just want to
have a yes yes or no answer so depending
on that you can adapt your your
biosensing device for this application
in general our chip base the direction
is is around
65 cents
um and it's also fast compared to the to
the ku pcr measurements that we've done
for measuring the micro rnas
of course at the end getting pickle
molar sensitivity is not the best
sensitivity that you would like to
achieve with the microending but it's
the
upper limit so but we would like to test
our system using clinical samples and we
do as little uh studies by using four
different patients together with a
control group and compare our results
biosensory results with the cool pcr
measurement
here the patient two and four are in the
in the progressive state of the tumor so
where we expect very high levels of
micro rna
19b um and patient one and three has a
has a surgery and they are they are
recovering from these two more and they
are getting so we are
expecting lower levels
and actually overall but you can see the
results are very well matching with the
with the coopies vr results uh we have
also uh we see also in the biosensing
fan um part better
um
better
not accuracy but better better uh
standard deviation so
um it looks in general fitting only on
the patient one we see a slight
difference um
for the for the ku pcr results which are
high a little bit higher than our
patient one measurement which we believe
which is comes from the the problematic
that the coup cr probes and primers that
we use could not even differentiate
between 19a and 19b and as i said these
in our system has a has some
at least some uh
specificity again against it so um we
expect these signals coming from those
um
another idea which was which i'm i was
thinking is so mixing everything in an
epi and then putting on a chip so why we
are not doing that on a chip directly so
why we need this
um so and come up with the idea onship
cleavage is this possible and we show
that it's possible so the thing which we
change is we
we we build the complete essay into our
chip
and give
the crisper cut crisper cuff and complex
together with the crisper rna and the
sample to the channel and let it cleave
um
so what we see
um the system verb so we see that the
system worked but we had a higher
standard deviations and the limits of
detection sensitivity is decreased so
this is also something which we are
still working on because this would be
very powerful too so you will have one
pre-functionalized chip because we show
that our our sensors are also stable up
to nine months in a fridge condition
after this essay is built there so um
and in that way
you can just take it out put your sample
and wait wait the cleavage time whatever
and then
do your measurements so that would be
very
very powerful so one chip for all
micrornas for example so this is
something also research which is still
ongoing
and of course as i said um one microrna
does not help you and you cannot
diagnose anything with that so it could
be upregulated for one reason so we need
to have the whole picture so we need to
at least measure let's say four
six or eight micro n is simultaneously
in the same shape from the same sample
and this is actually also another topic
which which we are working on as i said
at the beginning as well so multiplex
analyzes and this year we will be also
able to publish our results um maybe
this is
too technical but i'm trying to explain
it so i showed you our single chip
single channel sensor uh where we have
an immobilization area which is shown as
black here and the electrochemical cell
so let's take the incubation area two
together with the electrochemical cell
later on these two are separated and our
idea was to put a spacer area to and
again another another incubation area
which is in that case area one so that
to measure to analyze with the same
electrochemical setup by a spacer which
separates the signals in this way
and if you repeat these for example four
times then you can achieve eight analyte
chips and and this is as i said we
already tested in different this here on
the left you can see the
uh eight analyte chip which is um which
is each each first channel is shown as a
blue and the next one is the red and we
also made and this is complete a single
channel so we have now different inlets
but in the final final if you are
measuring it it has only an inner outlet
on the bottom we also mixed this with a
parallel approach um and also made an
approach where we have four times the
same simultaneous after each other so we
on the on the right side the foreign
light chip is the reputation
of each um
of the
single analyte chip itself
and by using this we were able
um and as i know at that time also the
for the first time we were able to
measure two different micrornas using
crisp the same cough effector on the
same chip um in different concentrations
here we tested the microrna 19b
in a high very high uh concentration to
see very low signals and and no target
to see
high levels higher levels of signal in
order to check technically if everything
is fine and here on the image you can
see the peaks here um please note here
the first peak is important the next
peaks are actually the peaks which is
coming from the previous channel all the
time so therefore you see also some
following speak
um and this is also something it's
uh we what we are also currently working
so um
and here i'm also hoping that we will
present we just publish another uh
multiplex version of our chips and now
we would like to combine this with the
crispr
um
to to show you the newest results of
that
um in general just to give you a slight
comparison and i think here almost you
can see i wrote their crisper cuff
biosensors but this is independent of
maybe our senses many crispr cut or the
chris paul you can see here as
for all general
crisper cup biosensing what's the uh
flexibility so you need only crispr rna
so you don't need any specific probes
and
primers if you are not using a target
amplification which we not using and
it's obviously in a picomolar range we
are trying to also come into the
femtomolar range right now but even
there we could see at least uh in the
clinical samples we could see
um microenergy can detect micrornas
um
you don't need if you are working with
hearing aids you don't need any reverse
transcription time to resolve is around
four hours depending on the cleavage
time which we use in this work about
three hours in qpcr and for the same
micro nas we use 6.5 hours hands on time
is something which is still we are
dealing because we are not completely
integrated system so we are have the
biosensor yet
um multiplexing is up to 10 possible
uh with i think with
some kind of all biosensors but this is
also for the onsite of
applications
more than um enough i think if you put a
control
and and also um
a positive and negative control that
would be on completely fine in qpcr i
think around four is the limit
uh the costs are low we use only 600
nanoliters of sample to measure and
analyze um and as i said you need a
minimally trained personal right now but
this is have the capacity if it goes
if it's going to be commercialized
then it could be also easier what we are
also working right now is as i said we
are bringing the multiplex
now the next level of the multiplex
sensors
together uh with with the amplification
free detection now we we shortened our
protocol to 30 minutes and we are
working right now to measure uh
different um
different sequences of kovis 19
where we have an e gene as a first line
and then an eip gene for the
confirmatory and we have a negative
control for saskov one there are the ap
gene and a positive control we are using
micro n19b since we have already
validated it here on the image it's
shown as a single analyte but we will
definitely bring this also with our
multiplex chip since the new generation
is already there um finally i would like
to summarize my talk since i'm trying
not only to show what we are doing but
also give you a feeling what you could
do with the um
crispr cos
combined with biosensors i would like to
give you also in my opinion the future
perspective
um as i said
the the crispr diagnostics already
actually started to move to the point of
care
there are companies like shallow
diagnostics marmot biosciences so and
they have already point of care
kits or that you could use
um
but this is also something which also
the biosensors right now is using moving
in my opinion we need to get rid of the
target authentication
in any code so um this is either you can
use it such a system like the like the
kiana irons group with the crisper chips
that you use binding and a very highly
sensitive um sensor or like us in an in
a microfluidic channel using uh using
some microfluidic protocols to increase
the signal
but we need to go down since in my
opinion if you combine it with the
isothermal amplification
then it you you need again specific
primary probes then you you lose the
advantage of the crispr and i believe
critics per have much more potential and
regarding that actually if you are
targeting for example viruses what you
could do and also the dalmar group
already also shown
together with professor melanie
um
so um
you can target
the same
genome of a virus in specific different
areas to increase your target
so you are using three targets for one
molecule which increase of course the
the sensitivity of your devices this
could be done for longer sequences
unfortunately not possible for micrornas
but there are lots of different methods
to use these um authentication free
detections and i think this will be the
next
thing and it's already started again
um
of course but i believe not only the
multiplexing to measure different
micrornas simultaneously what i believe
we need to also go into the we will go
into the multi-omics so not only the
measuring and and the asset but
combining it with an antibody for
example
or
to use
crispr to detect proteins and not only
and for example by combining them with
some optimal which triggers and
if it's bound it triggers or um it
triggers a crisper reaction or it stops
a crisper reaction which allows you to
detect proteins i think this could be
also an important way where you can
think it here i choose an an example
which i can found um
in a soon um recently published way but
there are lots of potential out there i
think this is also something which i
believe this could be uh the next thing
and of course variables so variables is
doing the biosensing the next thing so
it's already started and it will
continue the next
five ten maybe 20 years
and here um i believe the the journey of
the crispr
definitely continue on the variables and
it's already started in in the in here
um there is also a talk um coming from
my colleague peter and gaian
from from mit
com who combines the face mask within
crispr custard the agnostics i think um
this is also the start of the crisper
into the variables and but i believe
this many many works will be some
patches or different
um again here we have um a huge
potential
um very big challenges and therefore i
think um crispr helped us there to to
solve um at least some of these
um
so with this i'm end of my talk this is
my group uh disposable microsystems here
um who and of course i would like to
thank all of my students and also
collaborators who um who are bringing
this research front i'm here the front
van to uh um to have the honor to speak
to you
um
and finally i believe in science so and
this is always one of my last slides so
i believe in science communication is
very important so we need to communicate
and this is
one of the current best way is to use
the social media here you can find me
under this link i would be happy to be
connected and share
our are inside sciences
uh and um happy to
hear your comments maybe as a last thing
um as an editor of a biosciences by
electronics journal we we had a crispr
powered biosensing
special issue um with with with kiana
with james collins and
and also the bonjour chakraboti so um so
we would be uh i think the deadline is
already done but if you are interested
just write me so um
maybe you can submit as a normal uh
document so that's also the normal
submission um with this i'm end of my
told and
happy to hear your questions
thank you can for your informative
presentation we will now start the q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
so let's get started we already have
some great questions coming in
our first question um what is the future
of crispr dx
um
in the in the
i think the as i as i also also
mentioned so i think the the most
important points are right now um to
achieving some some methodologies maybe
combining two different crispr reactions
together
or or doing some other amplification
techniques it could be either
microfluidic electrochemical or optical
to achieve to to bring the sensitivity
of whole crispr systems without any
isothermal amplification
um increase it so this is i think the
main point
and and as i've said uh the the
multiplexing would be definitely
something which is which is also
important
um and of course variables so this would
be um as i said i think this will be the
next thing so if you are looking for a
variable stuff so i would go for
combining to
crispr with variable
thank you for that
another question we have
a participant states this is a great
method but how could you overcome the
sample preparation time slash complexity
would it work with different bodily
fluids
um so in this work which i show actually
we work with with with with serum
samples of children
um and we used and and
and sample perforation so this is
something which is which is important um
to get rid of this is also maybe
actually thanks for this question this
is also very important and this is also
something very important i think and
also the biosensing community mainly
misses the spark point to the sample
preparation and even how this sample
preparation is done or the the block is
administered these stuff are playing a
role on the results so i think we need
here very
very good protocols in our system um we
said right now we would like to first
focus on the sensing part to get the
best
sensitivity since we don't
do not directly want to go to the at
home or testing so we can we would still
allow to use it
uh the sample preparation in an usual
lab
but
um in a longer run there are also
already some some approaches for example
i i saw for saliva samples um
how you could do some sample preparation
with without get um easily then we are
using whether using a kit
um
but i think this is definitely something
which which is also an important point
perfect thank you
another question we have um thank you
for a very interesting presentation for
the n application with the nz enzymatic
reaction take place on chip if so do you
think the cavs enzyme stability could be
a challenge and therefore decrease the
sensor's
shelf life
um and
the enzymatic reaction i i think here
the enzymatic reaction is meant the the
the cost and the magic because we have
also glucose oxidase the signal
generation
um i'm trying to add the report to be
safe on the safe side so cass is given
the the solutions in an um all-in-one uh
application which you see um i think
now you can see it again
um so in in this slide you can see the
here the the um
the glucose is always there but and the
cuff will be washed away after the
reaction before the glucose comes in
um so uh therefore i don't i don't think
that there will be any problem with that
um regarding in the channel and the
cleavage what i what i'm thinking what
is happening is
um
what we are currently in this on chip
cleavage
living is the the we having an and very
short reporter rna combined with a huge
antibody
combined with a huge enzyme because
oxidative is also not small so we are
talking so um each i think 160 kilo
dollars molecules and most probably we
have some accessibility problems of the
cost then some activity problems uh so
um this is but something which we are
also working on and studying right now
great thank you there's lots of great
questions coming in we have a couple
more here it says firstly thank you for
the presentation i'd like to ask about
your biodegradable study did you
investigate environment effects
especially microbiota
um
so
i don't know which biodegradable study
is meant here so um
so at the beginning
i believe the materials that we are
using will start to bio
biology to be biodegradable in an
overall run
to to to
due to the environmental issue in our
case our chip is only recyclable
and and we do not um
actually
this is actually regarding the
microbiota we have some some activities
in another sense using antibiotics
which we are also working on as a group
and multiplex detection of antibiotics
but not for the crispr
part
thank you
another question can you comment on the
precautions to be taken during mi rna
detection and how this will be
applicable for point of care sensors
so in the in the final version i am not
thinking for example that you are
sitting at home and
i would like to pipette something or
just
it should be much more easier so maybe
the device should be at the end a little
bit complicated so that either you gave
your saliva in and that's all that you
need to do and it's the the the
the chip the microfluidic chip is closed
and you have a whole automatic system
where you don't have any access and you
don't need to be careful uh you don't
need to think about it but in of course
if you if you are talking in the
laboratory so you have to be very
careful so you need to work on clean
surfaces so um rna contamination is i
think not not only um
a huge problem for us but also many many
people who are working on that field um
what we are using in the car solution is
always we are adding some rna inhibitor
to be just on the safe side um
because of course the cost is also in
um if it's not
uh very good clean so custom craft
solutions could also contain some iron
marinases so just to be on safe sides we
decided to add always rnase inhibitor
[Music]
perfect and it looks like we have time
for one more question
can you please discuss the sensitivity
of amplification free detection by
crispr without nucleic acid
amplification for future clinical
applications
um thanks for this question so this is
um as i said we are now in the low level
of the picomolar range um in the current
work we are now touching in this higher
upper limit of the sample model range we
have we have now also some ideas how to
how to push the sensitivity a little bit
further
um with using some electrochemical
techniques um regarding the applications
we are working currently on alzheimer so
we are looking for different micrornas
which can be find on patients because in
alzheimer's it's a really big problem so
we don't have any good biomarkers to
diagnose it earlier and it's it's really
horrible and for example i like always
this notice so if you are already on
over 30 um you're you're um you it's not
not requiring and you cannot change your
your your your future so either you will
have alzheimer or or not so you can only
delay it so it's a huge problem so we
need biomarkers which indicates it's
directly
earlier ages so that we can find it and
i think here micrornas
um could be
and something which can help us and this
is something which we are working on of
course tumor tumor area with the with
with cancer this is also a huge issue
um which we are working on
um
actually i did not work until the copies
with the viruses this is of course also
something but also the the
similar to
viruses the bacteria would be also some
problem and to be honest i was expecting
actually more and
by bacterial uh pro and cold problems
with due to the
super box or whatever than an uh virus
pandemic but
okay so that's um so i think these are
the um next
stop and definitely i agree with the
question so
sensitivity and issue sample preparation
and and other issues but we need to we
need to
um
have easy systems to solve these
problems since
as we also saw that saw at the beginning
of this pandemic so the stuff that you
need in an enormous so you need
materials so you need kits etc so it's
not affordable at the beginning if the
whole world starts to create or needs
even masks is difficult so talking about
not about the kids
um so i was really uh shocked that that
a country like germany was not capable
of producing
space marks at the beginning of a
pandemic
um with such an economy and such a
resources but this is the case and i
think from this pandemic we learned also
some some lessons and i hope that
this will never happen again
awesome thank you again can for your
time today and your important research
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions any
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years till september of 2023
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues and any anybody who may have
missed today's live event
until next time thank you goodbye